i'm ella yakubovska
i work as a policy and campaigns officer
at european digital rights
and i'm one of the coordinators of the
reclaim your face campaign to
ban biometric mass surveillance in
europe my name is gregory ingles
i'm from the european citizen initiative
freedom to share
it's an initiative targeted to changing
the copyright rules
to allow free sharing of copyrighted
material
and at the same time to reimburse the
authors
in a fair way so
hi so my name is shanet o'keefe and i'm
a member of the voters at borders
european citizens initiative
it doesn't make sense to me that you can
move to another country and you can
live in that society i don't know if you
have children you send your children to
school there
you work there you pay taxes you go to
the hospitals there
you take part in the community you
become part of the community you're in a
sports team there
and you can't vote it doesn't make sense
to me
we were really drawn to the fact that
the european citizens initiative
allows us to potentially influence eu
legislation
that's a massive thing and you know
sometimes the
eu can seem kind of remote to people and
it's not always clear how the eu's work
connects to people's lives so
the european citizens initiative being a
process that
anyone can launch and that requires the
signatures of
one million people means that it's it's
it's really broad it's a really great
way of engaging people
that might not realize that they
actually have a chance to influence the
laws that the eu creates
there could be some alternatives rather
than starting a european citizen
initiative one could run
a protest in the streets and and and
make a
simple petition but we saw that back in
2019
as we had organized a wave of protest in
the streets
protesting against the article 13 of the
new european copyright directive
that this protest basically um
not only went unheard by politicians but
actually been
actually mocked from from the top and
said like these are googlebots
and you cannot take them seriously so
we looked what is the instrument how we
can make ourselves
be taken seriously and by making
european citizen initiative
we are addressing directly the
commission and if we are successful
they need to be taken seriously looking
at
the different tools of direct democracy
available in the eu
we've we've looked at petitions and
lobbying
lobbying lobbying governments lobbying
the
institutions but we've seen that the eci
tool is the best
tool especially for young people to get
involved in and
yeah directly get involved in eu policy
making
when we first started the process of
getting our european citizens initiative
registered i think we hadn't fully
appreciated
the complexity of the process because
this is a
legally recognized process and you have
to
take care in how you write your proposal
and how you submit it so my biggest
takeaway really
is to get as much advice early on as you
possibly can
there are some really brilliant
resources out there through the
european citizens initiative forum and
once we started
taking advantage of those it got a lot
easier the way to register european
citizen initiative is long
and we had very fast found a team of
people across europe
from seven different countries that was
the easiest part
the complicated part was to write the
legal text
that is actionable upon so that has been
accepted by the european commission
and also to do all the administrative
tasks
with the new regulation it was great
because we didn't have to launch our eci
the second
that we had been accepted by the
commission we were able to take some
time to actually
build up partnerships um before we
launched so we launched september 1st
on 2020 and we had been accepted our
proposals have been accepted in march so
there was a really nice
gap that we could you know build up the
team and do a lot of research
and that's also where the eci form came
in because we did ask them i get a lot
of advice from them
about um kind of legal grounds and how
to
build up our strategy one of the
challenges that we faced when we were
seeking to register
our european citizens initiative was
which treaty basis could be the the
legal basis for
the demand that we were putting forward
to the commission and
as a group of citizen organizers that's
something that we weren't
100 comfortable with ourselves so
actually being able to
turn to the european citizens initiative
forum and ask for their advice
their legal advice was really really
powerful and made the difference with
the things that we weren't not sure
about
and they were able to give us some
recommendations
on on the legal basis for our ask that
led
to our initiative being registered in
the end
the problem to actually register the
official text
to submit it to european commission so
it can be translated and everything
this was complicated and also to have
the it set up was
quite complicated task even that we
felt that we know what we're doing but
if we would do it differently this time
i we would rather start with building up
a support network
and get more organizations on start
our experience with the commission's
signature collection website has been
very positive
when you click onto it you click i think
it's support voters without borders
initiative
and you can see how signature collection
in each country is going
um which is very good you can see the
the threshold the amount of signatures
that has to be collected in that country
so the threshold we call it
and the percentage of that that has been
reached
campaigning at any time is a challenging
thing trying to mobilize people
and translate at least for us what is
quite a
heavy policy message into something that
helps people
understand why this topic actually
impacts their day-to-day life
so we've had to think quite creatively
about how we can
get some of our content to be picked up
and
to kind of go viral so to speak um
on social media and one of the things
that we found that
is really really effective is to hook
what it is that we're campaigning for
onto things that are happening in the
news because that is where people seem
to be
most interested you're watching this
video so you obviously have found the
forum
and this is a good thing because i took
some days to find it
as i was in the beginning to starting
the european citizen initiative
and i could use some of the material
in this forum much earlier
a few people mentioned it to me at the
beginning that this is a lot of work
and i think it was quite difficult for
me to really
understand what that meant but in in
practice i think just being aware that
you really need to put in the time to
get a good effect with your european
citizens initiatives so at the beginning
making sure that you've understood all
of the obligations that are
on you and putting a lot of time and
effort into making sure that your
proposal
is within the the legal competence of
the european commission and seeking
advice to help you on that
um making sure that you've thought about
it not just from
the perspective of the european
commission but also people that are then
going to sign it
one last piece of advice that i could
give reach out to other people who are
running
european citizen initiative at this time
or have
done it previously because you can
actually support
each other and you can also profit
from experience and learn and also
don't be afraid we are all in the same
boat
you